welcome back to this show man who I've
been a fan of for so many years from
swingers an office space Band of
Brothers Boardwalk Empire currently in a
million little things on ABC but
tomorrow night Tuesday night back here
on audience the 18 t original series
Loudermilk starring this man Ron
Livingston good to see you sir you too
rich right back at you appreciate you
coming back here certainly on a day I
thought okay Ron's gonna be on on Monday
there's bears coming off a bye week yeah
they're in Miami Miami's a stout team
yet but I'm sitting on game day morning
the pregame show on the NFL Network
yesterday Ron and and and Brock Osweiler
shows up for the Dolphins and I thought
like that was fresh Khalil Mac lunchmeat
yeah what do you think going in that
game yesterday you know I I took it for
granted a little bit more than I should
I thought we had that one in the bag but
um hey man the Dolphins say you got a
first of all we got we have a history
with the Dolphins you got to remember
all of our Super Bowl teams lost to the
Dolphins in Miami so this is our year
that's right right right right I feel
about as good about it as you can about
an overtime loss like that it was a we
you know and I mean like you had a lot
of miscues you had a lot of mistakes and
yet we still had the shot to win the
game a couple of times didn't come
together this time but I just I love
this team you do like them you're in
your your fire much my wife says too
much what do you mean give me an example
of too much I just get I get really
worked up about it you know I'm a guy
that gets worked up is this the only
thing you know like I don't I don't
sweat my own shows nearly as much as as
I sweat the Chicago Bears uh I don't
know it just gives me something to get
excited so now do you have to watch
alone like is that well I have a five
year old in the two-year-old right so
that changed everything you know like in
my 20s I watched it with a group of guys
and then they all start getting married
off and disappearing and you know and
you're wondering where's everybody going
and then you know you get married and
all of a sudden it's not you know and
now I'm like DVR and I'm trying to avoid
a little I got to watch it
the
first half live yesterday in the second
half without anybody telling me what
happened but sports blackouts a
difficult thing in the 21st century we
hard there's a lot of like sometimes I
got a wait till Tuesday going well you
know as whose day you sometimes can
stick five-year-old the two-year-old
some I just have no choice sometimes
it's what it's the sacrifices that you
make Parenthood for families you do
great well Chicago Bears football in the
last couple of years you could sacrifice
but right now I I I just sense there's
we had again your coach Matt Negi was on
the show a couple weeks ago love him he
was awesome yeah he was awesome like he
he gets it he understands you know what
how to communicate in the 21st century
or not and they're dialing up all of
this stuff true Biscay looks like he's
he's got the right guy and impressed me
actually especially about Mitch
besides you know coming out at halftime
and and really putting it together his
his postgame his postgame interview okay
was a little different side of him and I
missed it what oh you know he was there
was one of the reporters asked him you
know about the interception and I think
any looked at me said yeah you like
those interception questions thank you I
can always count on you for that I don't
know there's a little bit of it there's
a little bit of an edge to him oh and I
like to see it on him cuz I feel like he
came into the league I'm not gonna I
don't want to say boy scout but he came
into the league as a guy that wanted to
be wanted to be doing the right thing
and wanted to be doing what he was asked
to do an ambit of north you know what I
mean and like one to be like tonight I
really got it like wanting to set
himself up as leader of the team I feel
like he's he's becoming the leader of
the team well I think Chicago you know
Chris over there is from New England and
Chicago New England Philly oh yeah and
New York we kind of like our sports with
a little attitude yeah you know you
don't want somebody just you want
somebody to Shane McMahon there you go
the punky QB yeah
putting McMahon
on his on his headband yeah in the day
you know Rozelle he put Roselle on his
headband right there you know yes
Michael Steve McMichael you want that
sort of stuff yeah you want you want o
you I think you want guys that you know
have have one foot in the asylum you
guys I think every good defense has to
have three guys to have one foot in the
asylum and I'm I'm not sure who ours
would be but yeah I can take some guess
are you that way about the Bulls - or is
it just the matter no I'm you know I'm a
spoiled sort of Fairweather Bulls fan o
because I lived there for the first
three championships and uh you know and
then I kind of like in the town then I
mean when Jordan crazy cars were getting
tipped oh I mean it was so great it was
exciting because it in in those days you
could be you could go into the fourth
quarter 15 behind and you knew we were
gonna win the game because you knew
Michael was just gonna like put the cape
on and and and you know and make it
happen and it was it was a lot of fun to
watch Ron Livingston here on the Rich
Eisen show how come you're not on
Twitter or Instagram I'm old I think I'm
old and anti-social
you know show like I don't need you know
so you're perfect to play louder though
like if they had antisocial media I
would do that it's funny my wife's on
Instagram but it's got a private account
mm-hmm and I'm like you know they grab
our social media social media that's not
anti social media it's called social
media sites it's you don't even you
don't even do that well that's it
wouldn't by the way that's a good way to
keep sports blackout is if you're not on
Twitter or anything like that yeah it's
it's tough because I'll get text from my
father-in-law
you know when they win and I've tried to
teach him to like no you can't I don't
do that so he's got to maybe give you
the the Ru or you know what's the worst
is the people that feel like they have a
great poker face and they can like go oh
yeah no I'm not gonna you know what I
mean but you can usually read whether
they tell people when I'm in sports
blackout don't even tell me they say oh
the score because I'm gonna start
reading you like yeah so if you're
telling me that you know the score does
that mean that it's gonna upset me right
you know what's gonna make me happy and
I don't want to go through all of them
so just don't say a damn thing yeah let
me just watch the game but the problem
Ron Ron with sports black out yes
somebody who doesn't know anything about
sports but it's such a big game at you
for whatever reason could not watch live
yeah they will just finally just try and
connect with you on that front and yeah
blurt out this score like you don't know
words it can't keep it in yeah well you
know the other big problem about it is
if you watch a game live it's it's you
know three hours of heart attack if you
spread it out if you're not watching it
till Tuesday uh it's like ulcer you know
what I mean cuz it's not like I'm not
thinking about it on Sunday or Monday I
guess I you know obviously we do what we
do for a living here I can't even
conceive waiting two days
I know yeah but you know you got a job
description got a lot you got a lot
going on in your world Loudermilk
starting tomorrow night right here on
audience we're very excited about it
here on campus you know you've been
working on this show for for a couple of
years now what's going on with your with
this show and your character and what's
happening on this program um it's really
taking off you know this show is kind of
blossoming in the second season my
favorite thing about it is the world is
just populated with with all these kind
of misfits and numbskulls played by
fantastic actors and in the first season
you got to kind of focus on you know the
main guy and then maybe the friend of
the main guy and a couple people and and
I feel like in the second season we know
everybody well enough that we can that
there's a lot of scene-stealing moments
that that these guys get to do now that
I feel like they didn't necessarily have
the opportunity for that season one now
do you enjoy playing somebody who offers
no fools gladly and just walks around
and just tells everybody buys a lot of
mine I love it it's like a free pass you
know it's uh it's the only it's the only
chat usually you come in and there's you
you bring you try to bring all yourself
into the into the studio and there's
about half of yourself that they make
you leave
side because most shows are based around
the idea that you know people are trying
to be their best selves and their most
noble selves and Loudermilk is not he's
he's he just embraces all these flaws
he's the you know he's the biggest a
hole in the world wakes up miserable it
takes it out on everybody and and then
the next day does the same thing so it's
it's a blast to be able to do that on
television yeah and again it's on
Tuesday nights 10:00 p.m. Eastern right
here on audience ATT original series I
would love to play celebrity true or
false with you if that's okay sure arias
parts of your previous interviews in
various parts of the internet have
collected a few facts we wanna know if
it's true or false okay here with Robert
[Music]
first up you once sang backup for Cyndi
Lauper truth all's true okay what what
gives crazy right yeah you know what it
was is back before Glee and back before
like acapella became cool again yes I
you know was in an acapella group in in
college and Cyndi Lauper was in town for
a concert happened to come to the you
know the club that we had a sort of
weekly gig at and asked us to come and
you know do join her show and sing
backups were so there for one show
mm-hmm and you have Connecticut I got to
sing backup for Cyndi which is which
songs time after time it was we did one
of our songs and then it like med lead
into time after time how did you do
pretty good the you know it was a bit of
a disaster in that you know I'm a Yalie
and the and then the New Haven kids you
know the they were like we came to see a
rock and roll show and why you got to
watch these peoples up there so yeah it
was it was a tough crowd but uh but yeah
okay next one bucket les your filter
your feature film debut was
Straight Talk with Dolly Parton in the
role of soldier is that a true story
that's true I danced with her so you've
sang with Cyndi Lauper danced with Dolly
Parton yeah I yeah and I said the bit
was I was that grabbed her ass so that
was the okay that was the bit was my
first film bit and she was I mean I
can't even like she was lovely okay you
know it was new and green and starstruck
and she couldn't have just been more
welcoming and you know David trying to
call my dad yeah you know she it was it
was great it was she was awesome so
Dolly Parton Dolly Parton in Cyndi
Lauper I'm one night I can go for the
week go for the Triple Crown here and
then the last one you told me just
before you came on you were handed a
3-iron on the set of swingers yes the
true story yeah what's this about now
there's a golf scene in and where Jon
Favreau and I are playing on a pitching
putt and apparently the props guy was
just told go get a couple of janky
looking used clubs and and and
apparently they didn't know golf so it's
um he brought like a 3-iron of you know
could drive or something like that and
you know I'm standing here and the
camera is about not much further away
than you and I don't have any loft at
all so there was actually a shot where I
hit it perfectly like straight at the
lens that would have broken the lens if
the if the DP hadn't like stepped in
front of it and he actually caught the
he caught a 4-iron to his light meter
and and we lost a light meter that day
yeah Ron I appreciate you coming on good
luck to your bears moving forward and
obviously the Loudermilk season 2
premieres tomorrow night right here on
audience so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience